what could you do to stop this giant
fire tornado or anchor this floating
house
[Music]
or keep these portable toilets from
flying away if your answer is probably
nothing then you're just like most of us
who stare blankly at images like these
on our screens every day sure we know
that these are the kinds of extreme
weather disasters that were predicted to
get worse with climate change and yeah
we know what to do to avoid the worst
impacts of climate change but as long as
there are giant corporations and
trillions of dollars clinging to the oil
industry it all seems pretty
overwhelming so maybe it's time to give
up these companies are not going to stop
polluting on their own so if they burn
through all the oil would it really
matter in the end how much oil can we
afford to burn how fast can we move out
of oil into renewable energy and what
are the stakes for our communities and
the planet this is what if and here's
what would happen if we burn all the oil
in 2018 the earth had about 1730 billion
barrels and crude oil reserves with oil
companies pumping out about ninety four
point seven million barrels a day The
Wall Street Journal estimates that
ExxonMobil Chevron Shell BP and total
pocketed about eighty four billion
dollars that same year these
corporations are making a pretty penny
on burning oil and releasing carbon into
the atmosphere but each one of us and
the planet are paying a very high price
for it
increasingly extreme weather disasters
human misery and massive extinction
among many other impacts of climate
change show us that we need an immediate
and ambitious transition into renewable
energy we can't afford to keep burning
oil and other fossil fuels as these
companies would want us to do so what
are our options for a viable future
throughout the years
Society has had a love-hate relationship
with oil on one hand it's used to create
a lot of products we use every day and
no I'm not just talking about filling up
our gas tanks I'm talking about shaving
cream toothpaste deodorant dentures
lipstick contact lenses dishes cameras
yarn and you get the picture this didn't
just happen out of nowhere oil companies
have worked hard for years to make sure
people depend on their products while
misleading the public about the climate
damage they were causing according to
Richard he D from the climate
Accountability Institute 90 carbon
producers are responsible for nearly
two-thirds of global industrial
greenhouse gas emissions between 1751
and 2010 and of those 90 polluters the
top four contributors are the
all-too-familiar oil companies Saudi
Aramco Chevron
Sahn mobile and BP simply put burning
oil releases carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere which then makes the average
temperature on earth hotter a study led
by the Union of Concerned Scientists
estimates that carbon and methane
emissions from the 90 largest carbon
producers contributed to nearly 50% of
the rise in global average temperature
between 1880 and 2010 and yes we know
you've probably seen hundreds of graphs
animations and presentations explaining
how bad the impacts of a hotter planet
can be but now those impacts are
becoming very real and making our planet
less safe a changing climate leads to
increases in the amount of extreme
weather including deadly heat waves
severe droughts and wildfires and it
doesn't stop there
increasingly hotter temperatures and
more droughts lead to lower corn and
wheat crop yields having less food
available causes prices to spike and
food shortages the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change has predicted
that reaching beyond 1.5 degrees Celsius
would make extreme temperatures more
likely increasing heavy rains in some
regions while creating record droughts
in others we haven't even reached that
limit and there have been unprecedented
bushfires and floodings in many regions
the same panel estimates that climate
change will make those already in
poverty even poorer it will also have a
negative effect on displacement and
immigration flows particularly on
communities that depend on agriculture
and we know all that could ultimately
escalate into social conflict and create
political tensions between countries so
what would be a good replacement for oil
any other fossil fuels such as coal or
gas would cause a lot of the same
problems
and replacing everything we use oil for
by turning to renewable energy would be
too expensive right well in reality
replacing oil and even fossil fuels in
general with renewable energy would
actually save us money and we already
have a strategy we can use in the US for
example the transition to clean and
renewable wind water and solar energy
would start with an investment of seven
point eight trillion dollars and this
investment would pay for itself over
time from energy sales it would create
3.1 million nett us long term full-time
jobs and save sixty-three thousand lives
from air pollution each year in the
country it might sound a little too good
to be true but we're already seeing
strides towards making it a reality in
2018 the world had more than one
terawatt one trillion watts of solar and
wind capacity installed and by 2023
we'll have another terawatt of capacity
at half the cost to the first as Elon
Musk puts it we have this handy fusion
reactor in the sky you don't have to do
anything it just works shows up every
day and produces ridiculous amounts of
power this all sounds great but do we
still have the luxury of continuing to
burn oil not exactly you see if
corporations keep extracting the
reserves of oil and other fossil fuels
we know about there will be nearly nine
hundred and forty two billion tons of
carbon dioxide released into our
atmosphere that would result in global
warming of 3 degrees Celsius 4 degrees
Celsius or even higher which is way
beyond the limit of 1.5 degrees Celsius
that experts agree is the point of no
return for our planet
so instead of playing the waiting game
it's time to actually do something about
all the environmental problems we see in
the media instead of feeling overwhelmed
and thinking of climate change as only
your responsibility start putting it on
the real culprits the corporations that
produce the most carbon emissions and
the government's that let them get away
with it get out there and vote whenever
you can for government leaders who will
push for enforceable social and
environmental laws and won't be captured
by corporate interests maybe one day
more governments will take a strong
stance against these corporations and
make them pay every time they hurt us
and our planet but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]